I have people messaging me saying that I
need to get picture a video the three of
us rubbing our heads together
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Manhattan fruit market where I'm
joined by Andrew ray and Anthony Fantana
first we feast fans you know Andrew from
is tremendously popular binging with
babish series where he recreates dishes
from your favorite TV shows and movies
and of course the Internet's busiest
music nerd serving up daily music
reviews on the needle drop that's right
it's YouTube's bald brain trust joining
together to turn your top comments into
reality we heard your calls loud and
clear review melet's review melons
review melons well now it's the moment
that you've been waiting for role in the
melons right up first we have a classic
it's the watermelon which is actually a
member of the cucumber family mainly
water over 90 percent to be exact just
six percent sugar I'm a big watermelon
guy where are you guys on watermelon
love it use water knowing that huge you
know everybody thinks of the watermelon
as a fruit but there are some who
classified as a vegetable it's actually
the official state vegetable of Oklahoma
when you said earlier that it was part
of the cucumber family it totally makes
sense because in a lot of ways of
watermelon does chew a lot like a
cucumber and luxury spas always make
water out of watermelons or cucumbers so
watermelon watering is a hangover cure
just like coconut water on the reviews
Anthony we want to start watermelons of
strong tap it's so first of all it
tastes so good
it's one of those fruits and one of
those foods that you just associate so
deeply with a certain time of year it's
great fruit Andrew watermelon is a hard
ten if you want to push it up to 11 hit
it with some dark rum and some mint
strong - strong 10 strong 10 I'm gonna
put it at a decent nine I want to leave
a little bit of a sealing there
because I want my shoes to be blown off
watermelon you've had it it's a classic
but I'm leaving a little sealing room a
little head space up next we have the
cantaloupe they're at their best between
May and August I'm very much not a
cantaloupe guy here's my whole thing
cantaloupe and honeydew have just
destroyed the fruit salad you know I
think that you know a good fruit salad
by how much Kiwi there is how many
berries there are how much pineapple
like I could appreciate cantaloupe in a
food salad he's kind of like a palate
cleanser because it's got a bland or
kind of taste so you have some
strawberry watermelon you have the
things that actually taste interesting
and then just a little bit of cantaloupe
to clean it off so everything doesn't
taste the same the worst thing about
this melon is that it will ruin any
fruit salad that it's in if a single
seed is present if I need to bite it
fruit salad there's some cantaloupe seed
in there I'm going back to bed and I'm
gonna curls in a ball and cry because I
hate hate them so much cantaloupe seeds
are one of God's many many mistakes
what's your number I don't know kind of
like generally a cantaloupe like it's
fine it can be good it has its place in
the melon world but it's not a top tier
melon today to me cantaloupe is just a
straight 5 I could take it or leave it
it can roll off planet Earth for all I
care get it out of my fruit salad takes
up way too much real estate Andrew where
are you cantaloupe can vary so wildly in
quality depending on the presence of
seeds and how juicy it is and if there's
any of that green [ __ ] on the outside so
it can range between a 4 and a 7 to me
so up next we have the bitter melon
popular in Asia considered medicinal in
some cultures good for diabetes good for
cholesterol good for infections the pith
and the seeds those are considered the
most bitter so bitter in fact that we
will not be eating that part of the
melon what we're going with is on the
outside we've sauteed it you really do
not want to eat this straight raw smells
like pickles
what do you smell in Anthony it just
smells really earthy and peppery I like
the smell there's bitter it is bitter
and it builds it's so strong it's like
now that was hard to eat but my tongue
naturally has like this kind of wincing
reaction to it that when you're eating
it it's hard to talk my body is
rejecting it I don't paint bitter food
just right off the bat like what I eat
this again steamed or sauteed merely by
itself unseasoned no absolutely not but
I could see it working with licence all
oils garlic you know give it a green or
something to kind of be paired with
what's your number I'm indifferent
toward it so probably around two five
but seasoned and sort of treated
correctly I could see that number
contention I'm a little bit you know it
intrigues me Andrew what about you it
intrigues me for sure I can see maybe
you could do a cocktail with this but on
its own a placid
- for me this was different it was
interesting it was very intense and they
don't try to lie to you this isn't
called the sweet melon it's all of the
bitter melon like they tell you up front
exactly what it is to me it's a four and
it's only a four because of the
medicinal qualities last but not least
the horned melon native to Africa but is
also common in New Zealand where it's
called the Kawano
now here we have a great cross-section
Andrew I know you love a good
cross-section what you end up doing is
scraping the inside of the melon and
then what you have here now is a cup
it's almost like a gel and then a ton of
seeds I like it I think green jello it's
very interesting to eat yeah every seed
is in like its own little sack you see
that I mean I like the taste it's a
little bit of a chore to kind of chew
because of the
there were just the oh I don't even know
what to call it but it's almost kind of
like a bunch of cantaloupe seeds do we
have a number Anthony I think it's
pretty intriguing fruit that's
definitely not as satisfying as like a
watermelon right and I guess I find it
kind of weird to be eating a gelatinous
fruit out of a cut but I was actually
pleasantly surprised it was refreshing
to me I kind of like the way the seeds
played with the gel it gave it sort of
multi-dimensional feel in my mouth I
actually enjoyed the experience I'm a
fan would eat again I'm gonna give it a
damn I'm gonna give it a seven okay I
would give it a damn - I'm gonna go
eight honestly because I really like the
seat placenta and it's it's very
refreshing and it's got maybe it's just
the color but it really it's got kind of
like a Kiwi vibe going on and I like it
would recommend to a friend I can't stop
eating that's the sign of a good melon
well it's been a roller coaster
experience through the melon taste test
at this point
I think it's time to bring all of our
contestants to the table and Crown a
king you guys ready so here we are at
the crowning ceremony
I'm sure there's a difference of opinion
between us so put your crown on your
king melon and tell us why Anthony first
watermelon watermelon flavor the
refreshingness of a crispness of a
beautiful color it's like a piece of art
tough to argue with that Andrew also
duple credible crown yep Andrew why
watermelon I've never had a bad word
like I said before I have had good with
watermelon and I've had great one and it
is reminiscent of summer a lot of flavor
there and the seedless ones especially
our miracle modern science listen I
cannot argue with you guys the
watermelon it's a goat melon every melon
enthusiast has watermelon and their top
3 dead or alive I'm not going there what
I'm doing is a little curveball it's the
old Sean Evans 12 to 6 coming at you I'm
gonna give it to the horn Belen
and it surprised me in so many ways and
then I like the elements involved it's a
desert oasis you could be just an inch
away from losing your life and all of a
sudden you stumble across a horned melon
and you live to fight another day I like
the color it's so beautiful I like how
it's a little dangerous to hold in your
hand got that extract everything about
it excites me so that's why I'm giving
it the crown with that time to roll some
credits and rurre binging with babish
make sure you subscribe
Anthony Fantana the needle drop and as
for me all I have to say is buy more
melons but good for you
[Music]